this is like i said the
uh third part of a series and
so the saga continues
so this is uh there will be no models on
stage
uh this is a data modeling discussion so
if you do not want to do data modeling
on cassandra you're in the wrong place
but don't move because i like the
numbers that's good so
um i was going to try to beat adrian on
head count and i don't think i'm going
to do it but i'm close i'm really close
so we started this whole series together
well by show of hands i guess not all of
us but
you'll get there so what the data model
is dead long live the data model
it was really all about going from the
relational modeling world
so my background is i was a relational
dba a
relational developer i think a lot of
you have probably been in the same boat
so how do you get from point a to point
b and
so that was really the start how to get
from
i model relational data with multi uh
you know multiple tables and
normalized data forms how do i get to my
cassandra data model
that that conversation went directly
into now
now you understand that part become a
super modeler was really
the transition into how to just make
really good data models
in general with cassandra and
that general and by that i say taking
just
your concept and how do you express that
using cql
and that's a cassandra query language
and cql has a lot of features
and a lot of things that people probably
don't know about and that was really the
point
as to how to how to do it and uh we
went through a few examples so today
we're going to do something a little
different um i'm going to recap
where we started but then we're going to
have just examples like real world
examples and that's where i want to end
this thing because i think everybody
learns better with examples
and i i know whenever i write code well
at least all the pearl i ever wrote i
copied somebody else's code and just
made some modifications
so um in bash scripts right there was
only one dude that ever wrote a bash
grip the rest of us just copied it
so same with pearl mike michael are you
in here i'm sorry that's the truth
yeah mister i wrote a pearl driver for
cassandra i'm going to copy it and then
i'm going to make my modification
so um so we're just going to go through
a few
little topics to catch everybody up
because you know we got to
so why does data modeling matter and so
i've said this before i just said it
this morning to pankage my friend
i said cassandra lives closer to your
application
and so this is really where the data
model is
much more important with cassandra
because
if it's living close to your application
there's no generalizations
and it makes you think a little
differently about how you deploy your
applications
so we always talk about well cassandra
has a right use case
yes it does have a right use case um i
was an oracle dba
what did i want to do in package i'm
going to go back and use you as an
example
we'll just use it for everything and
because it was what we had but then it
didn't work out for a lot of things i
want to do multiple data centers or
things like that
i love memcache i use a lot of memcache
but that doesn't work for everything
so we've gotten to this point polyglot
persistence
is where we're at now it's 2013
we store our data differently for our
different applications and for different
use cases
so when we do that we have the
opportunity
to really screw it up or make it cool so
i
i've seen this 100 times i work with
customers all the time
i go out and talk to people and i see
the wrong data model
or i see the right data model so the
right data model
winning and the wrong data model
there's a sad panda so let's not be
sad pandas this is what we're trying to
do right we're trying to do the right
thing
and you know there doesn't need to be
any sad pandas out there
then again we don't need a lot of uh uh
charlie sheens out there either
that would probably be a bad idea was it
tiger blood
so see how i'm on time
next all right so
when to use cassandra and this is the
nutshell version and
i put in little tiny text here it's real
tiny it's about
that big um these are oars not hands
the here's a few bullets and i think you
probably heard this enough but i'm just
going to reiterate
for the rest of the review crew here
we need to be more one data center
that's a requirement okay
well if you have multi-master active
active
what other choices are you gonna have
that eliminates a lot of choices
so how about the scaling problem i used
to spend
tons and tons of time trying to figure
out performance
and capacity planning and what did that
mean well
that means that somebody's got to give
me an accurate number well this is how
many users we're going to have
okay as an engineer what did i do i just
times 10
so and then all right i gotta call hp or
dell and say i want the biggest box
you've got
and that was capacity planning well when
you really have no clue
and or you're really not wanting to put
that into the problem domain
cassandra's a good choice because it
scales so well when you need it
so the other thing that i hear is i need
this maximum
uptime and what's funny is i feel like
people
have been lying for so long about uptime
because
i'm i did it too maintenance time
doesn't count on your
up time oh no that was planned
maintenance of course is down
well what do you mean you were down your
customers couldn't get to your website
well yeah but that was planned okay so
what did that mean oh you probably had
to do it like three a.m on sunday
and that was exciting so getting out of
that world is awesome
and so getting closer to 100 percent
uptime there you go cassandra is a very
good choice for that
um so
we also have the problem of money
because
let's just face it you know we go to the
vp of finance and say
yeah we need an unlimited amount of
money to this application because
it's going to be cool what's that going
to be no
so we have to think about dollars and so
we when we want to do scaling or we want
to do multiple data centers
how's that going to play out money wise
i bought a lot of oracle in my day and
when i used golden gate
uh that just quadrupled the price
and that sometimes made it so well i
guess we're just gonna have to deal with
it it's in one data center
okay and even then it wasn't that good
of a solution so
it just makes sense uh economically
and then the final thing
that's why we're here right we gotta get
the data model right
and i work with a lot of you on just
this topic and i
i've seen so many good apps out there
you know we i've left places where you
know there's just going to be some good
stuff happening because the data model
was just
perfect so
here we go what we're going to do today
we're going to go through four
real world examples real world meaning
i get to see it all the time and
we're going to try to go through those
it's not going to be a
deep dive into the application let's
face it we got an hour here
i'm going to be crunched to try to get
that much time in i want to leave some
time at the end for questions and
answers because i know you have a lot
i'm just quick disclosure i'm going to
be over there after my talk
so you can come up and talk to me let's
just try to but
keep in mind everybody has questions i
know that well i'll try to get them as
quickly as possible but
i'm not going to be able to dig through
your app with you just today but
there's plenty of time left in the year
so we can figure it out
um so we're going to go through the use
case
basically it's just here's what they
were trying to do is what they're trying
to accomplish
and then how we did that um now
i'm going to make sure make this point
if you see this data model up there and
say dude you cop
that's me you're giving away my company
secrets no i'm not
no i see these all the time so
there's i'm not giving away anybody and
in the case of
where i was close i probably anonymized
it some and i blended a couple too so
don't worry you're you're not going to
pop up here
maybe a little bit but not a lot so all
these examples are in cql3
we don't do any thrift on these but cql3
makes this a lot easier for us to
explain
so i'm going to express the data models
in cql3
it's going to be a lot easier because it
is a very elegant way to describe a data
model
here's exactly how you're going to store
your data and
there's some caveats with that we'll go
through real quick
but wait it's a trap yeah so
yeah here's here's the one that we hear
a lot um
cql doesn't do dynamic wide rows that's
that's why i'm using thrift dude come on
cql is lame no no it's not
i can't so uh
this is probably the thing that we all
need to just get over if you don't
believe it
and so we say there's some terminology
changes i know
as you know from the community this has
really been kind of an
interesting transition you know it's
it's moving from one house to another
but trust me we're getting there
together and i've seen
a lot of help on this so if if you've
never heard of thrift or you've never
used it then
this isn't a problem but i know where we
are we have some people in this world
and some in that world it does do the
wide rows meaning that you know you can
have
lots and lots of columns and when i tell
people that they're like but this is a
fixed schema
no really and jonathan did this
really great blog post i i really
suggest everyone
it was written out of frustration i'm
sure but we just really needed to get
this into a clear concise thing
and then if you go read it you'll see my
almost equally as long
response to somebody's comment which has
even more information on it so i'm sorry
i kind of doubled the size of that blog
post but
that is a really good read if you're
really just want to get your head around
it and more importantly
if you want to get into what's going on
behind the scenes how's the data being
stored
um even though i'm seeing it on the
screen as like rows and columns
what's really happening behind the
scenes it will help you
and we're going to look at some of these
models here
so oh can't put my hand in my pocket my
friend rebecca said
i put my hand in my pocket too much so
i'm not gonna do it anymore it's like
saying um with your pocket
first data model shopping cart
it's not yours it's somebody else's
so i put on here because giving
customers giving you money is a good
thing
for uptime right because that's true you
don't you don't want your shopping cart
to go offline
so here is the use case we want to be
able to store it reliable
meaning that it's when someone says i
want to buy something it goes in there
and stays there
and we want to eliminate downtime
because if that's not available
we're not making money again let's go
back to
what the point here is we're making
money on our website
so multiple data centers really if
you're if you're chasing up time
and you're in one data center i really
you're you're faking it
you're not doing it right so the other
thing is a cyber monday problem and i
heard
you know everyone has a type of problem
like that
not everybody but it it doesn't have to
be cyber monday you may not be selling
anything
black friday cyber monday you may have
another thing when i worked at hobson's
it was
you know students would show up at the
last second for everything okay that's
our cyber monday problem
it's just the thundering herd or
whatever analogy you want to use but
that problem is hard because you can
never predict how
screwed up people are and people are
just really i mean they're the best load
testing tool
because you will never ever ever figure
out how they're going to
act until they do it so be ready for
that
so what we're trying to avoid here and
what
has been the problem in this one is that
for every minute you're offline you're
losing
money and that's really not okay and so
you know that's that was kind of the
driver here and speed
you know that was the thing that amazon
did a couple years back
my history is in web performance that
was one of the things we were chasing is
the fact that
for every you know millisecond or 10
milliseconds of latency on your web app
uh it's some amazon calculated using
them they were losing a million dollars
now granted that's because they were
making billions but
come on i mean that's money and they're
losing it because people are pissed off
that they couldn't get to the next page
so let's fix that too
so here is my uh whiteboard um
those of you who have gone through my
whiteboard discussions before
um kind of looks familiar doesn't it so
here's my whiteboard
so my plan is that each customer is
going to have
one or more shopping carts that's right
we're gonna have something really cool
they can have two or three or four
shopping carts
um and we're gonna denormalize that data
so that we can get it fast
denormalizing meaning putting all that
data into the the same row so
when i ask for a shopping cart i get all
of the information back
so one shopping cart equals one
partition or that's a row
um on the storage uh on the storage side
so that means we're going to get
isolation we're level isolation
i'm not going to go through real level
isolation but if you go back a couple of
my webinars i talk about it some
and that's really how you make sure you
have consistent data on a single row
so then each new item is going to be a
column
so see i got a laser pointer so as the
cart goes in
i'm going to have this partition key
which is the row key underneath in the
storage engine
of a username with a card id and then
this
wide row it's just all these items and
it's going to be
who knows how big but that's cool right
because what if
somebody wants 103 items great how about
great five well you got to work i have
another data model to get them to six
but
um we we're going to try to make it so
that it's flexible so whenever someone
puts random amounts of data in there
great let's do it
so here's and i really love this big
screen
because last year i was on a smaller
screen and everything that i put up was
micro i watched the people in the back
almost fall out of their chairs they're
like what is that
so this is huge the uh
so what i'm doing i create i have a
couple of tables here so i have my
my user table up here whoops back back
back
there and my user table at the at the
top here
that it's just gonna that's just a
normal user or it's you know an entity
where we have a username and a
first name and last name but part of
this is i have a a set
ah now part two of my webinar we went
into collections
and collections are really a useful tool
in cql because they give you some
dynamic portion but they keep you on the
same row you can denormalize data
really effectively by end but also put
that random element on top of it
and so using a set list or map you can
do some things like that
now i use them quite a bit just because
i like that flexibility
but uh i think you'll see that they do
have some really
uh interesting uses so what i'm doing
here is i'm just
storing a set of shopping carts so if
one user has three
ten a hundred it's fine they can have
that many
and so whenever someone logs into our
website again thinking about this from
an application level
someone logs into our website they get a
list of their shopping carts as part of
the result set
then whenever i want to display those i
have those already
i can go get the the varchar is going to
be storing
that particular shopping cart so
what i'm going to do at this point is
that i have a shopping cart table
and there's a couple of things that i'm
doing here that are kind of interesting
so again it's going to be by username
who are they the cart name
and then i'm going to start having these
item ids down here now
these two things right here are going to
make up my partition key
so that's that's that part right here
that i created when i created my primary
key
that's basically one row so one user one
cart one row
awesome the item id makes it so
that it partitions into a wider uh
format and it'll put it all on one row
so whenever i put in new items
like up here so here's my one storage
row one partition
so i have here's my this is me and i
have a shopping cart called gadgets i
want
and then here's the actual item that i
want to put in there
and then if you notice i've created a
map here
at the end for dynamic information
and that that's again yes i said i use
it a lot but
it's effective um i'm going to use that
map part down here to put in these
random stuff like related information or
volume discounts
just things that are applicable to that
particular item
so when someone goes to my website and
they click on their on their shopping
cart
i'm going to be able to get all the
items out so
i have all of this information in one
poll
and it will be one row so it's going to
be pretty fast
so let's go back to our the way our data
is fast in cassandra
row lookup for speed and then we do that
slice or in this case
looking at a full partition for the
efficiency
this keeps us all in one node it's very
quick we're talking about milliseconds
of access time here
so this is great we're satisfying a
couple of things here
it's going to be fast for our users so
you know they're not going to walk away
um
the other thing is that this is going to
work really well in a multi-data center
model it's not over multiple rows it's
on one row but it's
it's i mean it's cassandra cassandra
just does multi-data center perfectly
so that's my shopping cart data model
see how i'm doing my time here awesome
user activity tracking now
i'm not going to go into a full-blown
data science thing here we've got people
that do that all the time
what i what i want to do this is
get into more of the where the rubber
meets the road the actual use case where
people are
using that data if you go to strata
you'll hear about all these cool you
know cool things that people are going
oh yeah we got this guy who's got a phd
in statistics who figured out
you know if i have this one user they'll
click on something and
if they click on that they'll buy three
more of these things and that was
awesome
well that's not what we're trying to
accomplish here what we're trying to do
is find action with that
we have we can watch our users so we
want to react to that
in real time as users are doing things
on our website
and i know we've all seen this before
it's a little creepy whenever things
happen like that
you're going on a website or you're like
on amazon
or google or something like that and you
click on something and all sudden things
start popping up that seem a little
related and you're like oh i do want
that
well that's that's part of what's going
on behind the scenes but you need to be
able to react to that in real time
if they came back to you say an hour
later and said
wait oh i think you might have wanted
something else too late i'm gone dude
so that's where the real-time component
comes in right
so we have all these application pods
that need to be supported and a pod in
in an application sense is that
they'll be in different data centers or
maybe in different racks
but they need to be spread out all over
the place and it could be that we have
different applications themselves that
are watching activities that could be
crosstalking to each other
um there's plenty of companies that have
multiple properties
underneath one umbrella so you get the
crosstalk between those
and the scale i mean that's i think
that's going to be always a good reason
so the the bad part of this is that
the company in question was was having a
hard time because they were losing those
moments
they were they knew that they had
actionable items that were going through
and they were missing them and you know
there's nothing worse than leaving money
on the table
um so in that case they needed to be
quick on this
um and hadoop is just too long now
hadoop can create
models and do things very well but in
this case they needed to actually they
needed to be right on it
milliseconds and they needed to be ready
to go
so here's our whiteboard again um i love
whiteboarding
so here's the kind of like a high level
diagram of what it would be so here's
our here's our dude
who's on our website and as they were
walking through
our website we're making decisions and
we have this uh
interaction decision algorithm that's
algorithm not algebra so that
that's going to be making those
decisions but they have to have
input now see hadoop or data science is
really good
for feeding up or figuring out those
models but then
it comes down to you need to have data
to put into the function machine
you know input and output and that's
a little harder sometimes so what are
you gonna do with that data
and sometimes it's not just one thing it
may be a course of action
maybe four or five things so i'm getting
feedback from my website all the time
now keep in mind we're trying to do this
at speed
velocity how much are we trying to do
this okay if i have
a lot of people on cyber monday all
clicking on my website and i'm trying to
get page lift
then we're probably talking thousands or
hundreds of thousands of clicks per
second
so we need to be ready for that so
every interaction point so as they go
through the system is being stored in a
table
and that's that's where all that speed
is going to come from
the long-term interaction we're going to
break that out into a separate table
now this here's a concept and i've and
if you've
had me in your in your office white
boarding in front of you you've probably
heard me say this a hundred times
do not be afraid to write to multiple
tables because sandra loves rights
so if you got to do five ten hundred
tables per interaction
awesome it'll do it no problem got that
and what does that mean that means
you're gonna be ready for the read or
whenever you need that data
so do that so in this case i have this
requirement i want a really short table
i'm gonna i'm gonna show you how i do
this but
i'm gonna have one table for that and
i'm gonna have a longer table for that
longer interaction like i wanna store it
out later
and that gives me some options um
then i'm going to use hadoop on that
longer table
but that means that the old the data
that's hot that's fast
i'm just going to dump it yeah that's
right i'm going to get rid of data
and that's kind of a cardinal sin in
data science but i'm going to do it
so the other thing is is i want to use a
reverse
series and you've probably seen me do
this a lot and i'm going to show you
why this really makes sense it's about
speed
we want to be as fast as possible on the
database so here's my data model
the data models i'm going to have this
these two user activity
tables one of them is hot and one of
them
is more of a long tail table and
really the biggest difference is how i'm
storing that data
in them so the first one
all right class remember this one don't
we um
reverse order is kind of my uh within my
secret web it's not secret it's just a
great weapon
reverse ordering again means that as i'm
storing data so i have my user activity
table
here's my person the time that it
happened
and then some activity codes with some
details but look at my primary key
the row partition is going to be the
username and then i'm going to have
my my columns all part of an interaction
time
so that means i'm storing this really
dynamic
row of data columns going like crazy all
the time stamps on them until it falls
off the stage like i'm about to
but i don't want to look up data
over there i want to look at the last
thing that happened
so i'm going to reverse that meaning
that i'm going to have
all my time series data reversed
naturally for me
and i see some people nodding their head
because they've seen me do this before
it's cool right but that means when i
say i want the last 10 things that
happened
you're looking at the last 10 things on
that storage row you're not iterating
over a hundred thousand items or 10
000 items to go to the end that's just
not efficient
so we're just going to store it in a
reverse format
on the longer tail table i'm going to
put the interaction date so now i'm
going to partition
the rows themselves so every day has all
the interactions for users
this is going to make it easier for me
to later when i want to run hadoop
where i can create a hadoop job that
will iterate over all those rows
per day if i wanted to do a range of
days it's just an easier query to do
but it's just formatted in a better way
and i'm not reversing it i'm just going
to keep it in its natural order
which is fine because whenever i iterate
again like with pig or hive
that's it doesn't really matter i'm
going to be iterating over a lot of data
anyway
so let's just keep it like this so
what i'm doing whenever i'm inserting my
data into user activity
is if you'll notice right here using
this ttl
i'm going to expire that data after 30
days i just want to have 30 days worth
of data in that one table
the other table doesn't have that
it's just gonna be forever that's cool
um
now bonus it's not up here but i'm gonna
tell you is another thing you could do
is your column family you could name
that
with a different name you could put the
month in there or a quarter or something
like that
so if you actually did want to uh keep
your column families separated or just
wanted to use that as a way to
separate your data you could do that and
so that that's just an option in there
but really this 30-day expiring
now again with ttls you get a delete for
free
pretty much that means i mean when we
run a delete on
oracle or even my sequel would you
run a delete in the middle of production
day
if you had to say delete a million rows
in oracle
no the first thing you get is a phone
call from dbas telling you you're crazy
but that's just going to create a lot of
redo logs this is a great solution to
that
how many batch jobs have we all written
called cleanup
yeah yeah so this is going to really
help out right because now you're going
to have this idea of
you know your data is going to be gone
after 30 days now keep in mind
there's no kill switch this is going to
happen
it's really hard to undo this so make
sure when you use a ttl that you're
using it the way you want to it's not
i'm gonna make it disappear no wait i
don't want to
it's really hard to undo that so just
make sure that's what you want your data
model
so now what how am i gonna use my data
when i have this now
so this is where that reverse really
helps things out
so up here i have my select from user
activity
limit five by doing that i'm only
getting the first
five items great very efficient
but what i got here was i got this whole
thing right here like
okay so i i logged in i went into my
gadgets i want i deleted it and then i
created one called
anniversary gifts and i went to jewelry
oh man the decision engine's on man okay
it's time to go
let's put some flowers in front of this
guy i don't know maybe a trip to cabo
where are you chad all right so um
you were gonna really use that
information effectively so
this is kind of a funny example but you
could think of some really
creepy things you could do with this
which is cool
and that's actually what's being done in
the real world this
this decision engine is really based on
the interaction what's going on
and storing just a few of those items
can really give you some interesting
insight and or
some actionable items for your
application
all right now uh what are we doing on
time
i want to make sure we have plenty of
time for questions all right we're good
log collection probably this is where i
came to cassandra
i had a lot of logs and i think a lot of
people find themselves here because of
uh the way that cassandra stores data so
there's two problems right log
collection it means that
something is spitting out a lot of logs
and it's never just one at a time
small bits no it's tons it comes like a
torrent it's just amazing amounts of
data out there that are created now from
machines
so we have to have something to keep up
with it so the high speed logging
part is that was a requirement in this
particular application
so we also needed to have our cassandra
nodes
near where the logs are being generated
now if we were in multiple data centers
with our applications we want to make
sure the cassandra nodes are
right there too we don't want them to go
across data center
last thing i want is a bunch of
bandwidth bills of all this data just
getting streamed all over the place i
want cassandra to manage the replication
in a more efficient way
but make sure that the applications just
connect to those local cassandra nodes
that was my
that's one of the big ones and then i
i also have this requirement where i
need to kind of pre-dice my data
and this is even better example of what
i was talking about earlier about
writing to a lot of tables and i've
advocated this so many times with the
rest of you and then i'm going to
really drive this home is why i hope
but that was one of the requirements
because we have dashboards
what would dashboards do other than make
c-level people happy
why else but i mean there's like a lot
of things on there oh it's pretty
but they're you know they have some use
i've i've been to the etsy office and uh
you know they have this wall of plasma
and it's just a bunch of
you know graphs on there and people look
at them
sometimes there's meaning in it but that
kind of stuff requires some
you need to have speed because a graph
from yesterday is
pretty boring and it really isn't going
to give you any idea what's going on
today
so the bad side of this is that the
scale and this actually happened to me
um i just couldn't get enough scale out
of my relational database for some of
the logging that needed to be done
if i de-normalize my data for one thing
then it hurt the ingestion speed i
couldn't index anything
it just turned into a big problem and of
course
i've said this many times before my
oracle box would scale right up until i
ran out of money
and when you're storing logs it's really
hard to get a lot of money for that
because
it's hard to say well this is worth a
million dollars of exit data
no it isn't all right so um
that was one of the really big problems
to get around and
so the batch analysis too it's just too
late
batch is batch batch has a lot of use
don't get me wrong i love doing data
science
on a lot of data but when you need a
dashboard
you fire up a hive job it's over
you know you lost everyone's attention
span and you know the people looking at
it they have a short one
so here's our whiteboard
so i'm gonna use flume in this case
um you can use other things like storm
um i even
scribe there's another one this is flume
because i have a lot of experience with
flume
and flume's job is to collect a lot of
logs you know like a log flume
and i'm going to use that flume
connection point to
create a sink which is a flume
terminology to dice up my data
so i'm going to take my my raw logs here
as they come in say from my web app or
something like that
and i'm just going to do three things
with it in this particular case
now i could do a lot more and i probably
should but in this case i'm going to do
a raw log a latest success and latest
fail
just really short bits of data that i
can get that out from
and then so with my raw logs i can just
do a lookup
that's one use case from the same data
point and then with my late
my successes i'm going to throw those up
into my next fancy graphs over here for
eye candy later
awesome so i'm really taking that one
data point and i'm doing multiple things
with it
really cool it's kind of like recycling
but um
this data model is not that hard it's
just kind of a concept thinker you got
to really put your
your mind and look you have to look from
it from where it's going to be the
consumer
ingesting this mini is not hard cause
xander can keep
up with this it's now we need to think
about our application from the reader's
point of view
so i have my three tables here
the log lookup is pretty boring
but that's okay because i'm going to
have a lot of other things going on
so the log lookup is just i'm going to
have a source so i have my source
my date so i'm going to be storing each
row is going to be one minute of data
because let's face it those logs can
come in milliseconds
so we have date up to the minute so by
using this compounding here we have a
source and a date to the minute is a row
key
and then just time stamps and that's
just going to create
how many columns we need just keep going
keep going keep going
so um the other thing i'm going to do
here is i'm just going to store the raw
log and i'm going to g-zip that
and that's a really good idea i've seen
this as a good effect in play a lot of
places where if you just have like some
json or
xml god help you zip it
it takes just it takes a few
microseconds in java
to run it through a compressor and then
it just saves so much on wire speed if
you're putting
a 2k block of text over the wire at
you know 10 000 per second it's going to
add up
but you can probably crunch that down by
50 or more
and all you're saving is wire time
that's good
and let's face it when you do a look up
like this you can then
reverse this and say give me all the
logs from this
source and this time you know this time
period
and then pull it back in and deserialize
or decompress it at that point
that's an application concept that works
pretty well but
our other two here are much cooler so
now we're gonna
we're actually gonna get into some
interesting uses of counters
now counters have good uses
and bad uses in this case i'm going to
say this is a good use case because
what we're trying to do is just create
numbers that will be graphed
for people looking for eye candy
so in the login successes here we're
going to have this source and date up to
the minute
again so we're going to do this
um as the same type of key except in
this case we're not compounding it
so we're just going to be marking these
sources and date up to the minute
and then marking each one of these so we
get counts
so that means that from a counter
standpoint and i'll show you the code
how to do it that means it's going to be
incrementing a counter in that minute so
if i have
10 things that happen in that minute
it'll be the count of 10. 100 100 that
sort of thing
but that way i can say how many things
happened over these many minutes and
i'll get
multiple counts i'm also
because i love it i'm gonna reverse this
so i can ask what are the last 10 things
that happen
last 10 minutes of things that happened
so
i've created two tables here you notice
i've created a login success
and a login failure i'm really busting
out this i'm dicing this
data way out here but that's great
because now
if i want to graph login successes and
login failures
different tables different calls but
it's very efficient because i just
pretty much created this massive
materialized view
very fast and as things are happening up
to the millisecond
i'm getting access to it on all my
dashboards or whatever graph i want to
use or something like that so this is
going to make my logging a lot more
effective
there so this is what i'm going to do
with that
actually created some data so we have
this one simple select command this is
really
what we've done the beauty of what we've
done here when we ingested that data and
diced it up
it made it so we have this opportunity
now to create this really stupid simple
select
and that's not going to be very long to
run that's going to be a few
milliseconds to run
and what i get out of this i say give me
the last 20 minutes because i know
everything's in there for a minute
so i get this nice graph of data and
if i hit refresh i'm going to get up to
the minute
on everything now if i want to change
that to something like milliseconds or
whatever that's fine
and the counters are going to be
counting along in the background
so notice that there was this little
window here i'm going to put this in as
an example because this is where
log data sometimes is really important
and i know
eddie i know you're in here and splunk
is awesome but this is a cool use case
too okay
you have these two minutes where
something bad happened with your logins
well if you knew about that tomorrow
because you ran it in batch
then you're just gonna be scratching
your heads so this is where this kind of
usage in these case really makes sense
it's like whoa something bad happened
oh yeah this login's failed and then
it's better now or maybe we were able to
do some action with it
so but this is that high flight data
all right i think that's enough on them
all right adam are you in here man
raise your hand all right baby i figured
it out
yeah sorry bud so user form versioning
and now
this is i i'm calling out adam because
he's the one who made me think about
this even more
it is really a use case that i i've
found a lot of places
and um so here's the here's a problem
that we're dealing with is that
we want to store the the version of a
form
indefinitely and we just want to have a
very efficient way of doing this so that
we have version one
two three four how many versions they
are we want to scale to any number of
users
and that that's you know always a
requirement we want unlimited scaling
and because we're going to have a
million users just like facebook
and we want to have to be able to we
want to be able to commit and roll back
our data
if i make a mistake on version two i
want to go back to version one
and if i say i want version two to be my
gold version it's going to turn into the
right
form cool so
i've tried to do this before in a
relational database and
it's not easy i mean it's a lot of
tables that have to be joined and so it
wasn't a very easy model there it's just
not an easy model anywhere really but
in this case i think this will work
really well
with a the way that rows and columns
work in cassandra
we also have this need where it needs to
be all over the place we have our
local data center which is where most of
our data is but we also have cloud
components like some of it's an amazon
or some of it's in rackspace
so it needs to live in both places and
that's really difficult especially if
you're trying to create
like a homogenous persistence layer
where it's maybe the same technology
it's not always easy to go from one to
the other whenever you're doing local
and cloud
especially if you want to try to get
them to synchronize in any way you want
to have them replicating
so these are some of our bads
so here's how it's going to work our
whiteboard session says
we're going to have this partition key a
row which is going to be a username and
a form id
but i'm going to store these blocks of
those form attributes
for each time they make a version change
and so i'm just going to keep growing
that out is you know random amount of
times if we have somebody who's a real
busybody on a weekend and they create 10
versions
fine i'm not going to have to deal with
that in any other way than just
my data model will maintain it we also
want to uh
separate the um the tables to have
we have the data that they're working on
and we want to have some stuff that's
live on the production site so we're
going to have these two things going on
so that all right that's
that's an easy requirement the exclusive
lock
now i hate saying the word lock
it's not so much as an exclusive lock
for a computer
which is a different problem it's more
of just making sure someone doesn't
stomp on somebody else
now it's funny because i've had this
discussion with somebody else about
why don't we just teach all our users
how to use git
okay yeah okay
yeah so we're gonna get a lot of admins
in like hr to start using git
no that ain't gonna happen so let's
let's think about this a little more um
in their domain how about a web page
just whenever you go to look at a form
you can see who's currently editing it
there you go that's good enough i mean
can you imagine somebody doing a cherry
pick on a forum in hr
no it's not gonna happen all right so
here's our data model so we're gonna
have a
working version which is more or less
just how we're that's going to be where
all the activity is going to be
happening
so we have the username and the form id
which is going to make up the row key
we have a version number which is going
to make all those rows
we're going to have a locked by and then
my one of my favorite collection items
the map
back here is going to have all those
different attributes of form attributes
that i'm going to be using
for this particular form id so that
means that if i change
any of this that i'm going to
increment the number in my application
and it's going to store the form in its
entirety
so that in each form can be different
and so that gives us a lot of
flexibility
and why not because i like to do it
every time anyway
it's kind of like becoming my boring
trick but it's very effective
reversing that so that my the last form
that i was using is the first thing on
the stack more or less
so whenever i want to get the latest
version i know that it's right there i
don't have to iterate over a bunch of
stuff
that's that's just really in general a
very efficient pattern with cassandra
so we have our first version that goes
in the system it's going to look like
this
so i have this i have my own little
coding scheme here where
i'm going to have a text box called
first name and here's the name of it
here's the display name and here's
what's gonna happen with the html
so this is my first version so when i do
that
i create that that's version one
so i'm gonna lock this for i'm gonna
edit it again so that just means i'm
gonna put a username inside that table
so whenever i go to edit that table
one insert puts the username in there so
if other users come in to use it
you can read that and say is it blank or
is there somebody there oh there's
somebody there okay i'm going to go back
and display to the user
oh user p mcfadden is uh using that form
right now
okay i can't touch it that's a lot
easier than get
but and i think for our use case it'll
be fine
now if you want to modify that a little
that's completely possible i'd love to
talk about some of the
all of these models probably have
variations that i would love to talk
about
these are meant to be somewhat
simplistic so we can get through it in
an hour
but there's lots of variations in here
um
and i know that you probably have some
really cool ideas and i want to hear
them
so we have this version number that is
locked so whenever i
finish it and i say here i'm done you
know i got my form finished up
i'm just going to put a null in here
whenever i increment it to the next
version
so that pretty much releases the lock so
the next person that comes along is
going to
read that and it's going to be empty and
they'll be fine now this is all
happening at speed
across data centers my local data center
my cloud
it's all there very easily replicated
data
that's it so you got four models out of
this
and i hope that what you can get out of
this is just some
some ideas these are that's what these
are all about i haven't given you the
full picture
but hopefully i've given you something
that you can work with
i i get asked all the time and i'm
actually i'm pretty happy to hear
i mean not for my own personal
edification but that i hear people say i
watched your video on data modeling
good use resources i i do these webinars
and these modeling sessions and
so that it can help you because i when i
first started with cassandra
i had so much trouble with data modeling
i mean i was trying to
shoehorn my relational model and it was
horrible
i know this is a need so i figured it
out i'm you know and this is a community
i'm going to try to help you figure this
out and so
you can do this this is very doable
so that means that yours is next
and i want you to think about what
you're doing right now and i know a lot
of you are working on projects right now
and things that you're doing uh
currently
because i've talked to you but you know
try out a few things and really
iteration is the key here there may
there's a lot of different ways to do
these so try different ways to do them
see how they work and if it doesn't work
one way
and you really get frustrated find us
there's there's
we're out there the community is out
there engage an expert you know
i'm not that hidden if you've noticed
i'm kind of obvious
come out and find me and you know
twitter um
if you follow me on twitter i talk about
data modeling and cassandra topics
all the time and you know that it's you
can use it like an rss feed if you want
and
i've had a lot of people you know
contact me about data modeling and
as much as i can do 144 characters i can
help you
but sometimes it turns into a larger
discussion
that is the point i'm trying to make is
engage people i
really hate to hear how people tried a
project with cassandra and failed
because they couldn't get their data
model to work
when they didn't even ask so ask people
are here to help
i mean look at all the green shirts we
have in this room raise your hand if you
got a green shirt on
oh yeah so that's good for you
all right that is all i had um i think
we can do
some questions and i so here's the rules
on questions
i'm not going to rewrite your app but
if you have general questions about why
did you do this or
how did this work you can go ahead and
let's ask those questions but if it's
going to take like
i need to know all about your
application let's try not to go that far
so where's our mic let's
i saw man oh man there's a lot of hands
up
we're gonna play the lottery
let's just start over here and then
we'll walk our way across
so when you do multiple writes you're
replicating your data to multiple
locations
um and obviously there's bugs in your
code and you're gonna make mistakes
you're gonna write it in correctly to
one location and maybe do another
is there processes or tools or
concepts that have emerged to help make
sure that you haven't hosed yourself by
as you write that data to multiple
locations because writing bug free code
is not an option
all right so if you're if you're in a
position where you're
writing code that and you're deploying
new code into your cluster
and you have the potential of writing
bad data essentially that's what you're
talking about right
yeah that that is probably the reason
number one
why you do a backup on cassandra is not
because you're gonna lose your data
it's because somebody hosed it for you
and that happens
all the time um so in this case
snapshot is your friend i always tell
people before you do a code push
do a snapshot and a snapshot is
literally that it's a point in time so
if you're going to do a snapshot
right before the code push and then also
your code deletes a bunch of email
addresses
right on pocket do you remember that
don't you all right so i'm gonna point
out it wasn't his fault by the way
but it was uh it's gonna happen and then
you can use that snapshot to get your
data back
and there's a lot of options with that
but just first and foremost do the
snapshot
it's oh it's almost free on the file
system it's a hard link
over here hey patrick
hey there we go you i knew we were going
to ask a question
okay go ahead how rigid should your
model be if you're going to be
using solo for you know a lot of
searches
the solar question so solar brings out a
whole new thing
and really you probably want to think
more of your data in terms of your solar
schema
than cassandra if you're using it for
just solar
if there's a blend then you have to
think about that but keep in mind that
if you're
you're overlaying solar on top of
cassandra the solar schema is fixed
here's what you have you can put dynamic
fields in but really it is fixing the
scheme in some way
so there's a little different way of
doing that and probably more of a deep
dive about your application
but in general that's how you would
handle it all right one more over here
uh hi on the last example you gave
there is an update you were doing and
that's a read before right so
it normally says that you try to avoid
those and
so what is the basically a general
rule of thumb where you were okay to do
read before right and were you
not yeah i know i knew i was going to
get that again
oh i broke the rules no the read before
the right is really about
you don't want to do a lot of those like
if you're doing
read write read write read write in this
case i'm doing one read to see if
there's anybody there
and it's user based so if i click on a
link i get a read
and then i can i'm going to make a fork
action on it i'm either going to move to
the next form or i'm going to give them
a different form
saying it's locked right now so it's not
in the application i'm not reading and
writing it
like one after the other i'm doing a
read and then if there's something going
on in the application
that then will result in a write so i
mean
that's i guess my my cheesy way of
saying i'm not doing a read before right
not in the way that we wouldn't want you
to do it which is right after the other
in the same block of code
i had two small questions so um first do
you think
um i saw it in this secondary index as
example do you think is
less important than expiring column or
exclusive log in your examples
uh you're talking about secondary
indexes why didn't i use them
all right so in my second webinar i
think it was
i talk a little bit about secondary
indexes i feel like secondary indexes
are a crutch for relational folks
because
they think it's speed secondary indexes
are
built for convenience and not for speed
and
i try to avoid them in general just
because there's a lot of confusion
but if there was a case where you did
need it i would call it out in this case
i didn't have any
and i think you'll find that if you do
your data model correctly from an
application standpoint
the need for secondary indexes is very
minimal
i mean there's there's always a case for
something right but i feel that that
means
it's a very small case in this the
second
question is someone said thrift is
better to help you
form the habit of cassandra do you think
is unless one of the reasons
is better than the cql thrift is better
for what
from the habit of using cassandra
instead of the like
regular traditional sql syntax
yeah that's that's what i hear too i
would suggest reading that blog post
it's it's not like that
and i i think there's just a lot of
people that are have been using thrift
and i was one of them
it took a while for me to get my head
shifted around and understanding it but
it really
in that blog post and if you read my
comment on it it's really about
understanding what's going on in the
storage engine
what's really going on here cql is
abstraction
it's it's a way to make it look better
for the user and for the application
the storage engine hasn't changed that
much there's some there's some different
things going on but not that much
it's still doing the right thing but
it's forming
like a it's giving you the correct path
to get to that right
thing so that's that's why i advocate it
all the time
you're going to have a better data model
yeah can you talk about limitations on
collection sizes
if any and in your lock
model they're just curious what happens
when two people
ask if it's locked or not at the same
time
i knew i was going to get that one too
so you never put a lock up that's why i
said oh no i put a lock up there
because you always get the lock guys you
know wait a minute
um so the first question collections are
do have practical limits and the reason
that there is a practical limit is
because it cause you have to deserialize
them so that can cause a performance hit
i
i talked about this in one of my other
webinars where it's really about your
where you're at with your performance if
you're looking for the most performance
the serialization is not something
you need to take lightly so if you put
say a hundred thousand things in there
or
ten things in there there's going to be
a different cost right i believe there's
actually a hard limit of 65 000 right
now
um i don't know if there's anybody from
a cassandra cork and you were
i think that's what it was 65 000 right
now but then again
you probably don't want to put that many
in there anyway it's not a it's not a
substitute for a good data model
it's an augmentation
all right oh second question how do i
manage out of the lock
i don't have a good answer for that it i
mean there's collisions that can happen
at that point if you're really that
worried about those collisions
and um what i would probably say is that
you can then create a different model
where you put a time stamp along with
the user you create a locking table
and then that way if you do have two
people in there at the same time
you're going to see that there are two
and so you just augment
that row or that column value so that
you have a little more information in
there say a timestamp is really good
so that if you do have two in there that
you then you can flag that as a problem
it's all about the knowledge that
there's an issue
all right so yeah i'm not gonna talk
about 2.0 features i'm talking about
what you can do today
but yeah check and set is really the way
to do that and
thank you cassandra core developers
because you're going to make my life a
lot easier yes
so in your user activity table you had
four or five columns plus a clustering
column
so every insert will write essentially
five columns to the storage engine
is there a concern of the table getting
far too wide above the typical ten
thousand columns or
twenty 000 columns that's considered you
know
safe for cassandra which table was that
let's see the oh you mean the initial
one well there was date to the minute
so it only stored up to the minute of
that data so there would only be one
minute's worth of data in that
one column family or in that one row
so if you were collecting logs say every
millisecond
that's going to be a lot yeah i mean in
general what i look at for
the width of the column is more about
the volume of data that's in there and
not
the count because what you're trying to
avoid
in this case is an incremental
compaction so we're really getting into
the weeds now
so the incremental compaction that i try
to avoid is say like that 64 meg
limit on a mem table now you can make
that bigger if you wanted to to keep
that from happening
but in general that's what i look at now
if that's going to be a problem
in this case let's change that to every
100 millisecond bucket or something like
that you know you tune that
there's some teams probably in here that
i've worked with where we've done that
where we've modulated that
row key so that we can get a different
column based on what you're trying to
accomplish
if you don't mind having an incremental
compaction because it's not really an
impact on your system
fine let's have 300 000 or 500 000 or 2
million
columns but if that's more of a concern
because of performance later or you
don't have the i o to take it
then okay let's figure this out that's
that's the
try things and then measure
do it again and this is how we do our
development
more i saw a bunch of hands yeah um
again on that same table there was a
clause in there with
i think it was with clustering order by
right
and you had the uh the time stamp in
there
right um i i clearly don't understand
how that's working because
it seems like you'd have all of the same
time stamps together and if you're
looking it up by
user and time stamp that you'd want it
clustered by
user and timestamp
okay so this guy right yes
uh date to minute um
i think we're called user interaction
okay
all right hold on back a little farther
back
this one yes all right okay great
yeah so the row key that one partition
of data is going to be the username
and then every column
is going to be a tiny ui ah okay
clustered within
the row right ah okay then thinking
relationally so
sorry that's okay we'll beat it out of
you
as a community we do that as a service
right
now it's fine because that's that's
where you think about
what your application needs i i really
wanted that in some sort of laid out
format and this is one of the great use
cases for cassandra is that temporal
data
probably the go-to move for a lot of
people and then unfortunately i hear a
lot of people say well it's only good
no it isn't but you know thinking about
wow that's perfect because now i have
this one row that i'm looking up of a
source
and i need that data over a certain
range like with time it makes perfect
sense because what do you always do with
time data you say oh give me
the last 10 minutes or give me three
days worth or something like that
um so yeah putting those in individual
columns does
one seek on the disk that's what we want
very fast more
oh hi hi uh when
doing your data modeling are there
special considerations
when you're going to be storing binary
data up to say five megs and a column
i you can and that's why i always say
compress if you can and so if you
actually i have worked with people that
are doing that large
log files or something like that or even
images
there's plenty of use cases the thing
you have to consider whenever you put
something
large in a column value is the wire
cost or you know how long it takes to
get something over the wire
if you put something two meg in a column
value
just based on the speed of ethernet
you know you don't expect that in 10
milliseconds it's not going to get there
that fast
but you know that's that may be okay for
your application
maybe you have a larger sla so that's
really the biggest consideration
and then again how many columns you have
you know you may
get to a large physically large column
like a
lot of megabytes that will generate a
different type of compaction
but it's more tuning and that may not be
a problem either
especially if it's somewhat like cold
storage so to speak
we always look and again back to our
application
what is the important thing here if your
sla
is the most important thing like i have
to have every read
come into 20 milliseconds 30
milliseconds okay
let's tune for that if you're i need to
be able to write 100 000 per second of
this
but i don't care how fast i read it out
completely different
story that's why we're thinking about
our application first
and not our data the relational way was
i got a lot of data how can i dice this
up you know i got a bunch of normal
forms
so that was thinking it from the data
standpoint so
i i mean i kind of gave you the bigger
answer on that i hope that helped
hey patrick i was wondering about the
future support
for native sequel 3 in solar
and hive and how soon do you expect that
to be mature
here's five bucks for answering that
thanks zack
yeah that'll be in a couple weeks um
so data sex enterprise which has hadoop
and solar
this is one been one thing that our
datatex enterprise team has been working
on
very hard really what we're talking
about is cassandra 1.2
which has a lot of great features
virtual nodes it has
it has the cql native
transport those are two very good
reasons to be on it
but data sex enterprise is using
version 1.1 to get to version 1.2 we had
to make solar and hive
be okay with using things like virtual
nodes and so
that's pretty much done so that'll be
out
pretty soon and you'll probably have it
before you know it and
i'm happy to say that so dse team you
rock
thank you very much so luckily it's not
i don't know
any more questions more
uh-oh patricia doesn't get an ass
question
all right fine oh thanks
so so i had a question about
so about size constrained columns or
size constrained rows
so i know it's not practical to to
constrain
your rows based on a set number of
columns because then you have to do the
full read for each row
every single time you do it right but
could you have
could you have a use case where you set
a counter column
for each row and then check that counter
column
only and sort of
go through and do do a hack uh
constraint that way
i think you just answered that you said
the hack word
no i wouldn't do it that way because
that all right there's your read before
the right okay you have to read the
column value and then do a write
or yeah you'd have to do it right or
even do another read with that
so you're asking like if the column
count is say 10
000 or a million or something like that
what would be the
like the constraint what are you worried
about in that case
like having too many columns and having
a good count
just having yeah having too many columns
having um
just keeping the size of the data to a
certain size
well you're not right so if you're
worried about that from the beginning
i would say that we would need to
consider the data model as that's the
problem
i don't want to have too many there's so
it's kind of a more advanced topic
there's more interesting ways to
modulate
how many columns you have by using the
row key
and i would prefer to explore that until
you ran out of it
before you do anything with the word
hack in it you know if you have the word
hack in your solution
you're probably gonna that's gonna come
up in the next sprint because someone's
gonna say you can't have a hack
so yeah i would i would look at why
you're even worried about that and
address that problem from the beginning
and just eliminate because if you if
you're creating a counter column for
every time you put in a new column
then i i really feel like that's a nanny
pattern
and that's unfortunately the answer
thanks you're gonna
you're gonna follow up aren't you you
are
all right one more one more
who's uh you've already asked a question
but
oh there's one um i was wondering if you
had any oh you didn't ask
me so sorry any thoughts on like using
sets and collections as primary keys
in data modeling oh uh
no creative
no yeah i don't think you could do that
wow i've never done that
um
no you cannot because of the way that
the collection is created
it would not work um but
that's an interesting idea why would you
want to do that i
came up in a thought experiment with
some friends okay
that's an interesting so there were some
artificial constraints but see what
what you're all right so let me try to
go down that rat hole with you for a
second
if you're creating a dynamic data
structure as your unique
key that may not be the best idea right
well the idea is that it would be
it would you would create it and then it
would be immutable and then
that you would use that immutable set
as your primary key if you're creating
an immutable set then just create the
right data model in the first place
okay
i mean i'm not trying to be harsh but i
mean i'm just saying that that's one of
those things where we sit there and talk
about it because
if you really say this is immutable or i
have fixed fields then you don't need a
dynamic data structure
sure yeah sure okay all right
i'll be over here